hey there I'm Claire I'm a tasty
producer and today I'm going to show you
some of my favorite recipes to make for
the kids in my life personally I don't
actually have kids but my mom and I are
the caregivers for my six-year-old niece
and my three-year-old nephew basically I
get to be this really cool anti mom
hybrid superhero and it's hard but it's
also really really rewarding when they
suddenly came into my care I had to
quickly learn how to cook for kids and
let me tell you it was no easy feat and
I was lucky enough to be able to channel
it into my work by making tasty videos
and tasty Junior videos my coworker
Hannah she has the six-year-old son his
name is Jackson and he's my best friend
and he's usually my sous chef in all
tasty Junior videos we have been cooking
together since he was 4 and I've gotten
to see him blossom into such a
kind-hearted and goofy boy we have a
blast together in the kitchen and he
brings so much joy to the office when I
would eat something so as all parents
know you don't always have time to cook
everything in the morning during the
week and it was my nephew's birthday I
wanted to make something super
innovative and special for his birthday
breakfast and he loves cinnamon rolls
and who doesn't love birthday cake so I
made a cinnamon roll out of birthday
cake and they were such a hit at home
that I had to make them into a tasty
junior video now I know what you all are
thinking who gives their kids so much
sugar for breakfast but just to see the
joy of his face when he woke up to a
cinnamon roll birthday cake he was
ecstatic and it made the experience of
making it just that much better so in
order to fuse cinnamon rolls and
birthday cake together I had to figure
out a way to get that cake flavor
without adding extra sugar I ended up
just using a box of pre-made cake mix
and adding flour to the cake mixture to
make it more of a dough consistency
rather than a cake batter consistency
and it worked like a charm they're
fluffy they're sweet they're cakey
they're everything you would want in a
birthday cake cinnamon roll hybrid
having to all of a sudden pack lunches
for two kids was super intimidating at
first when I was a kid I remember
getting made fun of for having certain
things in my lunch and I really didn't
want that for them but I still wanted
them to have nutritious lunches which I
know can be time-consuming my time was
already so limited in the mornings and I
needed a quick solution so I thought of
how adults
meal prep for their week all the time
and so I just adapted it for the kids it
teaches kids the responsibility of
packing their own lunch
my niece loved that responsibility and
she was so proud to walk up to her
friends and show them that she had made
it for herself and I could see the
confidence growing inside of her and it
was great for me too because doing just
a little bit of preparation can save you
10 minutes of time in the morning that
extra 10 minutes allowed me to be able
to brush my hair or have a cup of coffee
or spend those extra few minutes with
the kids and it also sometimes will give
me that extra 10 minutes of sleep which
is so valuable this is not the only
thing that you can make for your kids
lunches have it fit your needs it's all
going to be catered to your family and
what your family likes but it's just
designed to save you some time
and as much as it saves time for me it
also teaches my niece some
responsibility to pack her own lunch is
such a big deal because she feels like
she is serving a role it gives her an
opportunity to participate in our
morning routine and she feels like she's
a part of it and that's really special
for our family we want to include them
and raise them to be independent human
beings and this is just one of the ways
in which she is learning to be an
independent person
everybody has their go-to favorites when
they're cooking for their kids in my
house tacos hands-down are the winner
but they're always such a mess
especially with a toddler so I was
trying to figure out a way to work
around it and then the taco breadsticks
were born kids love tacos kids love
breadsticks so why not combine them I
know it's not traditional in any way
shape or form but I really enjoy being
able to use inspiration from other
classic dishes around the world to make
them fit my family's needs my nephew can
hold it with his hand and not make a
mess all over the table or himself
getting a kid to try a new thing can be
really difficult so if you play with
their personal flavors that you know
that they like it will be much easier
for them to eat it if they know it's
taco flavored or Pizza flavored or
something familiar to them but in a new
form at my house I serve them too
send a few as an appetizer or a snack or
even aside at dinner they're just a
special treat the kids love and it blows
their minds just about every time dinner
is probably the number one most
frustrating thing for parents when
cooking for kids it can take a lot of
time and effort and by the time you're
done cooking they're probably just gonna
turn their nose up at it and say it's
not what they wanted there was this one
time I went to dinner with my boyfriend
and his family at this really nice
expensive Japanese teppanyaki restaurant
there was this child across the table
from us whose parents had ordered him
this really nice steak dinner that was
cooked right in front of him and it was
really exciting for him but all he would
eat was his fried rice that's like $30
worth of dinner and all he ate was fried
rice and I was like dude you've such a
great dinner in front of you why are you
only eating fried rice and then it
dawned on me
kids love fried rice duh so that
experience inspired me to create fried
rice and to play with the flavors of
fried rice because yes it's not
traditional again but it is an
opportunity for me to show my creativity
through the food that I make for the
kids I don't know about you but I've
never met a kid who doesn't like fried
rice so if you can play with the flavors
and customize it to your child's
preference you've got a solid hit for
dinner that night as much as we would
like to be we can't always be model
parents and our kids can't always be
model children luckily my niece and
nephew are perfect and they usually eat
their vegetables but sometimes I do have
to get creative with this dish I really
wanted to take the classic childhood
favorite of a cheeseburger and bring it
to life with a little bit of healthiness
to it I added some broccoli and carrots
honestly I don't even think the kids
noticed that there was anything in there
they're not little investigators like I
know some kids can be but I know these
kids and I know that if there was a
plate with broccoli and carrots and a
cheeseburger on it those broccoli and
carrots probably will get ignored
believe it or not I do read the comment
I've noticed a lot of parents shaming
other parents for having to hide their
vegetables in their kids food and if
that's what works for their family great
if it doesn't work for yours try
something else and if you have a perfect
child who eats every vegetable that
crosses their path
you my friend are lucky parent if you're
still finding it hard to get the kids to
eat something too
Green Anna try involving them in the
cooking process they're more likely to
eat what they made because they have a
sense of pride in it and you get a good
bonding experience cooking together
I am a mean Baker but I'm not the best
cake decorator so I was looking for
something pretty foolproof that even I
could make for my niece's birthday when
we were planning her fifth birthday
party I'd ask her what theme she wanted
and all she would say was unicorn that
was it it was gonna be unicorns and she
would accept nothing else the kids had
recently started living with me and
shouldn't know that many kids and she
was new to the area and I really wanted
to give her the most amazing birthday
possible she's such a great kid and
she's been through so much that she
really does deserve the best I went from
being a free-spirited easygoing 24 year
old woman living with my best friend in
Los Angeles to a parent basically
overnight and I'm not gonna lie it was
terrifying and it still is terrifying
because I have these two amazing little
people who rely on me for everything in
their lives we've had a lot of
opportunities to learn from one another
and they have made just as much of an
impact on my life as I feel like I have
made on theirs I don't know if I
personally will ever have kids but I
will say that I am more than happy to
give all my love to these two kids for
the rest of our days I'm not gonna lie
and say any of this has been easy it's
been the most difficult time in my life
so far but I wouldn't trade a second of
it for the world even though I'm not
their biological parent I still have to
face the day-to-day activities that
parents do with their kids
I made this amazing cake and I brought
it out to all the kids at the party and
they were all so excited the cake got
devoured in about 10 minutes on the way
home from her party she had said thank
you so many times but she says auntie
you know I loved my unicorn cake but I
just want you to know that it did kind
of look like a cow too and when the
video got posted on the Internet the
commenters also thought it looked like a
cow which it was not as cute coming from
them but it was adorable coming from her
so yes it does look like a cow but it's
a unicorn cow and it's unique these two
little kids are the most creative and
quirky and funny people I've ever met if
I can foster that and channel it into
being in
vente Vande cooking and being creative
with me that's the best activity we
could ever do together food is my love
language and it's how I show the people
in my life that I care about them
cooking for these kids has been such a
journey of trial and error and it's made
me a better cook in a better aunt
because of it and I just have abhorred
every second of this journey that's not
true I've complained a lot but it's fine
[Music]